[Music]
the first computers used to be the size
of an entire room then they were built
to fit on your desk the newest design is
a portable device that sits on your lap
and today's laptops are made even
smaller and more powerful than ever with
its lightning fast processor in
impressive graphics this laptop is
designed for high performance gaming the
computers brain called the motherboard
begins as a printed circuit board it's
pattern of lines and pads and copper is
the wiring for the electronic components
that will be soldered to the board
this machine places a stencil of the
component layout onto the board and
apply solder paste through the openings
a quality inspection camera photographs
the solder paste and sends the images to
a computer the computer analyzes them
looking for any missing paste
misalignment or other mistakes if the
board passes inspection it passes
through 15 robotic machines each of
which places up to 150 components on the
correct locations on the board in just
30 seconds then the board runs through
an oven that melts the solder paste
connecting the components to the board
another camera inspection ensures that
the internal processor is correctly
soldered and that no component is
missing or shifted at a position after
function testing and a visual inspection
the motherboard moves to the assembly
line and is set aside for the time being
next technicians manually assemble the
top half of the laptop called the panel
kit they place protection film on the 15
inch LCD screen then they plug in the
cable that will connect the LCD to the
motherboard they insert the LCD screen
into a frame with the web camera and
microphone already embedded then they
attach this antenna bottom cover to the
screen cover and position the
motherboard cable inside it next they
install the module for the webcam and
microphone they attach two hinges which
connect this panel kit to the rest of
the laptop
then they install the Wi-Fi antenna and
the antenna bottom cover all components
are concealed in the antenna bottom
cover behind this antenna top cover they
complete the panel kit by pressing in a
thin metal frame around the screen next
they assemble the bottom half of the
laptop first technicians attach the top
cover to the panel kit hinges and the
touch pad then they install the right
and left speakers in the top cover
now the motherboard comes back into play
after inspection a computer-guided
router cuts out openings to accommodate
the computer's fans which prevent the
electronics from overheating a gaming
laptop generates a lot more heat than a
regular laptop and therefore requires
two powerful fans rather than one after
checking that the fan screws are
sufficiently tightened they place the
motherboard into the top cover
contaminants such as dust or oil can
impede proper contact so as a precaution
they clean the connectors for the memory
modules with solvent then dry them with
compressed air then they install the
memory module the Wi-Fi and Bluetooth
module and the solid-state disk which
stores data
they connect a high-capacity battery to
the motherboard batteries for gaming
laptops are typically larger because the
faster processor indole fans
consume more power the last component is
the keyboard which fits into a
rectangular opening in the top cover of
the bottom half a laser etching machine
marks the required information
underneath an automated machine tests
numerous functions and a quality control
team test several others including the
virtual reality feature the LCD and
keyboard color displays and the keys not
only must the keys function properly
they need to be durable so enthusiastic
gamers won't break them while playing
[Music]